February the 6th potentially biggest NHS
strike in history are you confident it
can be averted in between now and then
is what can you do to get around the
table with the unions to to get this
strike hold off well we were engaging
with them last week my door as I've said
throughout this has been open we want to
work with the trade unions we recognize
that the NHS has been under significant
pressure particularly with this massive
spike in flu a hundred times more people
in hospital admitted for flu compared to
last year a very sudden increase seven
times more flu cases in December
compared to November that on top of
covid on top of the legacy of the
pandemic has created huge pressure on
the NHS and shoot pressure on NHS staff
and we absolutely recognize that that's
why we accepted in full the
recommendations of the pay review body
and we want to work constructively with
the trade unions in terms of this coming
Year's pay review process recognizing
the pressures of an inflation and
recognizing the pressures on the NHS is
there a deal to be done between now
February 6th well I want to work
constructively with the trade unions in
terms of the pay-per-view body process
those are the discussions we have that
is a constructive way that I and other
ministers are engaging with our
respective trade unions But ultimately
we need to act in the interests of the
patient and the 6.6 billion pounds that
we announced at the Autumn statement for
the NHS on top of the 7.5 billion pounds
the biggest ever funding could increase
for Social care of any government is
about listening and hearing to what the
NHS have been telling us which is we
need to address this issue of those who
are medically fit to discharge from
hospital that creates the blockage
that's about getting social care working
in an integrated way with the NHS that's
why we put that 7.5 billion pounds of
extra funding in and getting the
capacity into the hospitals so we can do
as we're doing here at Northwick which
is get that triage into the emergency
departments so we get the patient to the
right point in terms of their care we'll
find a question let's let's talk about
the patients the the government
estimates that tens of thousands of
people of treatments and appointments
are being missed today tens of thousands
more presumably in February as well this
is seriously damaging all sides isn't it
government patients and and the NHS well
that is why the trade unions need to get
round the table engage with the
Pay-Per-View body process look at what
is Affordable in terms of The Wider
economy the pressures on inflation what
matters most not just at NHS stuff but
all stuff is that we get inflation down
because inflation it cuts across the
cost of living for NHS staff social Care
staff but people across the economy so
we need to get that inflation down
engage with the pay review body process
work constructively together that was
the spirit that we had discussions last
week I'm pleased that Trade union
leaders themselves recognize those
discussions were constructive and
Collegiate and we want to work with them
but the right approach is to use the pay
review body process this coming year
talking about is Affordable both for the
NHS but to The Wider economy and message
to patients who've missed appointments
today well we're focusing that 6.6
billion pounds on how we get those
elected backlines down we hit the first
Target the first milestone in the summer
in terms of the two-year weights that
contrasts with Wales where there's over
50 000 people waiting over two years so
within the English nxs NHS we've been
driving down those weights we did that
with the first milestone in the summer
getting those two-year weights down
we're now focused on the 78-week target
as the next step in that plan we have a
clear plan to address the elective
backlog and that is what the additional
funding we're putting in is focused on